salut aujourd'hui je vais essayer de
mentaliser quelqu'un de très spécial
très spéciale parce que c'est mon chien
sevani sais pas si je vais là mentaliser
ou juste l'embrouillé avec un tour de
magie mais je tente un coup avec un os
qu ça c'est pour toi je ne sais pas
c'est assez incroyable ce qui se passe
la nuit attention tu es prête mais net
tu veux donner neuf car je ne sais pas
ne me regarde pas comme ça éliminer les
parties où il est là juste là lui la
justice'' il est passé regarde la
croquette
elle est juste ici la technique du chat
s'il n'y a pas de croquettes je m'en
fous je te laisserai les doigts en
conclusion je pense qu'on peu embrouillé
et un chien ont brouillé un chat un peu
moins parce qu'en fait il s'en fout de
base le chat s'en fout mais je suis pas
sûr de pouvoir les mentalités je profite
de cette vidéo pour dire un grand un
énorme merci à tous les abonnés qui
viennent d'arriver vous êtes vous êtes
légion vous êtes milliers vous êtes
venus surtout grâce à la vidéo de pierre
cros est vraiment pierre cros merci
beaucoup de m'avoir invité à faire une
vidéo avec toi j'espère que cette chaîne
en tout cas va vous plaire à vous tous
les nouveaux abonnés que vous allez vous
trouver bien chez moi il ya une vidéo
par jour tous les jours pendant un an si
cette vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez
laisser un pouce en l'air c'est pas une
moralisation si ça me mentalisme
prenez le temps de m'écrire dans les
commentaires je lis tous les messages et
j'essaie de répondre à un maximum bien
forcément de franchir le cap des 2500
abonnés j'avais promis qu'on fera un
gros live comme ça un apéro live je vous
en dit plus dans la vidéo de demain je
vous donne tous à la date comment ça va
s'organiser comment on va faire ça et on
va se faire démoralisation live portez
vous bien et rendez vous demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mentale blog
ciao